[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John old Humphrey we are going to watch
today a video 28 times
drawn together made you feel bad for
laughing remember drawn together see I
didn't so I had to ask J cuz this is a
patron video request everybody who
requested was definitely doing cover and
put up on YouTube it comes from J and it
says here draw together was a TV show on
Comedy Central back in the early
thousands drawn together use caricatures
he's quoting something I don't use air
quotes correctly alright drawn together
use caricatures of established cartoon
characters and stock characters in
addition their character traits parody
personality types that are typically
seen in reality TV shows alright well
I've never seen drawn together this is
gonna be an introduction for me I've
never actually seen it I just remember D
let's check it out
next of kin whoa holy moly this makes us
bottom cracks about my breastesses
lactating cherry and milk have you been
all night
[Music]
[Music]
ha
[Music]
[Music]
no you have to kill live-action cow
between them sweet brown eyes and
covetous mouth so we can't say if you're
gonna be gay about this you've been
drinking liquor and beer and cops are my
kool-aid and gray kool-aid and
[Music]
really friendly goes oh that feels great
sender I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he'll be more diseases dumpy the parents
being that's not entirely true too
I mean Jesus probably loves you
[Music]
everyone loves me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's weird to experience the show just
boiled down to one kind of prolonged
moment Wow what is this show I've never
heard of it
it's like Big Brother but with a bunch
of archetypical characters all living
together in a house and being raunchy
and stuff it's like parroting like
famous cartoon characters yeah if you
took famous cartoon characters culture
cartoon characters as well yeah and put
them in a reality TV house Wow
yeah this ran for like a season 2004
2007 on Comedy Central's yeah that kind
of comedy needs yeah now's the time for
that was the time I think with it all
the movements that have been happening
now we could use this so we can be like
lighting up yeah
cut it out everyone's so sensitive yeah
grow up hair get some thicker skin and
watch season 14 of drawn together my
favorite thing with the way the
movements have been is when comedians
are coming out going to make a [ __ ]
joke anymore what if the next stage in
movements as comedians writes to or
something yeah that's the big one we're
building to is finally joke right yeah
like we are on that path I really want
to go back in time and figure out how
long people have been saying that and if
it's just been since the dawn of
stand-up comedy especially now I'm
hearing it significantly yeah yeah
something like this I've seen when they
try to do sitcoms with this kind of
humor and it just doesn't fly by as well
and live-action format I remember the
names of the shows it was like Michael
Rapaport was a star one and then there
was lucky Louie lucky Louie who's on his
way they would come back apparently I've
seen other ones to that and they always
tank yeah because there's something
about it where it just seems ugly and
mean-spirited it's not to say this
humour isn't either fires happy now but
there's the thing about when it's
animated or you can be a little more on
word for it because most of that is
worse than anything I've ever seen on
Family Guy yes and I've seen like most
of family guys so yeah see this and go
wow they they really went there yeah
yeah yeah by the sound of it by the look
of it they went kind of all over the
place this is like the whole goal is
just to shock you as much as possible
[Music]
stuff like that where you're like this
is so horrible and yet I'm laughing it's
so ridiculous though whatever it's like
making fun of it oh my god how is uh the
ads racist sexist it's homophobic it's
all these things and you wonder I guess
once you pass a certain point of like
well this really does seem to be
offensive towards everything is it
offensive at all anymore like I feel
like that you can go so far into a fence
that once you're so offensive it's like
it's not even surprising and then it's
time again yeah oh he's so interesting
to see this show come out now yeah well
I'd be curious to see what a whole
episode is like I mean I gotta imagine
the tone is akin to this but these are
obviously the most shocking moments
taken and run together so I wonder what
22 minutes prolonged of this would be
like to watch I don't know I gotta find
it guys get it down you gotta watch the
movie others a direct-to-video film huh
that's great so why one direct-to-video
they're like we can't afford to not get
this in people's right now you know skip
the theater I mean thanks for the
request Jay this guy jasmine is such a
longtime supporter of the channel and is
also a loyal patronage act it's a
product designer is also that's like
ultimate creative time and I can see why
you're such a creative type knowing the
things you're gravitated towards
reaction channels and shows like shirani
yeah it's dry it's you know colorful and
there's a lot of rich humor and whatnot
you know I'm sure this is fueling your
creativity a really positive direction
yeah I can't wait to see what you make
based off I want to see it a like a
really reverent hand-drawn reaction
video that's what that's what you gotta
do
well Jay I hope you can see new be
creative I know sometimes we have
therapy talks as well
and I think after knowing the kind of
stuff you like makes more sense why you
good I mean I know I go to therapy but
it makes sense way you go to therapy oh
yeah pledge money we're just making
jokes all right guys well should we
watch drawn together we're gonna can all
the shows we do reactions to on patreon
I switch them all to drawn together I'm
gonna react episodes on my own you're
gonna react episodes on your own that
we're gonna both do them together yeah
an upload of seven times a week guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification value no watch check
us on patreon TV show reactions Q&A as
he does music video coverage and there's
also other reward tiers come by becoming
patron eject